from axios twitter refuses to remove
marjorie taylor green's transphobic
tweets i have so much to say here we go
queen twitter on monday labeled but
refused to take down a pair of highly
transphobic tweets attacking admiral
rachel levine the assistant secretary of
health for the us department of health
and human services why it matters
twitter has a practice of often labeling
but not removing tweets from elected
officials that would otherwise violate
its terms of service the tweets linked
here misgender levine while also using
extremely vile terminology to describe
gender reassignment surgery twitter's
move means that people have to click
through a warning to view the tweets
twitter will also limit sharing of the
posts
what they're saying quote
the tweet you referenced violated the
twitter rules of unhateful conduct
twitter said a statement to axios
however we've determined that it may be
in the public's interest for the tweets
to remain accessible and has been
labeled in line with our policies i just
want to pause real quick and say
if there is a barrier to seeing a
statement from a public official twitter
is engaged in politicking they are
engaged in providing special favors for
certain politicians and political
ideologies
that
has to be stopped okay
like imagine if during the civil rights
movement all the big companies were like
you're not allowed to advocate for these
things because they're unpopular so we
won't even cover them in the newspaper
or if we do people have to pay extra i
mean you need people to be able to talk
about ideas
glad
the lgbtq rights civil rights group
condemned the the move saying
this account has repeatedly and
intentionally violated twitter's hateful
conduct guidelines against targeted dead
naming and misgendering of trans people
a glad spokesperson told exious it's
clear that some politicians see pushing
malicious anti-trans content on social
media as part of their election strategy
even with the full knowledge that such
content is violative um
i'll say this
jamie brought the point before the show
that marjorie taylor green uh do you
want to just say it i mean okay
i'll set this up so you can read
so you can read the tweet oh no we're
not going to read the tweet
oh we can't you guys have to okay you
guys have to read guys guys listen to me
everyone grab a drink and go read the
tweet because it is a masterpiece uh
this tweet is so i mean i think both
left and the right would agree yes it is
taking something
that should be super simple that we
should all agree on um
do not give sex changes to children
that's it that's all you have to say
heard
she could have spent less time tweeting
if she just wrote don't give sex change
to children and then she could have gone
and hung out with her kids or done
whatever she did instead she was like
what if i write something completely
nuts and i'll have some rhymes in there
and i'll just and like i can't she will
make
things that should be simple
insane and in fact and and offensive
where it's like hey i don't like wearing
masks and she's like got it i'm gonna
bring up nazis and you're like no
so
i can understand the anger hands down
admiral rachel levine made a video
advocating for affirmation of children
which means tran sex sex change
operations for children and medical
intervention and sterilization and
things like that
and marjorie taylor green naturally is
angry but marjorie taylor green uh look
you know we've had her on the show we'll
have her on the show uh again soon i i
think there's a lot so much about it
that's fantastic the way she challenges
congress
in this instance
and and and we'll talk about it because
something like alex stein is going to
happen again but i just feel like
the the righteous indignation wasn't
there instead it came out as like
unserious like silly
it's hard to take her seriously when she
takes stuff to like an offensive and
ridiculous place it's trumpian yeah it's
trumpian so i i gotta say this
you know
we're talking about it now
and maybe that's why we see a lot of
this if she came out and just said this
is wrong we wouldn't be saying anything
about the issue of giving sex change
operations to children coming from the
government
right advocacy coming from the
government and so you know look
i don't like the way she framed it
i'm glad the conversation is being put
in the forefront and there's a problem
in this country if that's how it has to
get done so let me make this point about
alex stein i criticized him for calling
aoc big booty latina and i'm like what
does that accomplish and then it turns
out a lot actually because aoc then came
out and called 1-6 effectively an inside
job because of the lack of security the
capital and i was like wow
that's like
really strange pretty cool but let me
just say like we got a problem
with i guess humanity
if you have to do things like this to
generate a conversation about screwed up
things because i was about to make the
exact point that you made
with stein where i was gonna be like who
is thinking i'm gonna let my kid
transition and then they jump on
facebook and they're like peen queen and
then suddenly they change their mind who
is that actually helping even us talking
about it we're not talking about
it we're not talking about child safety
right now we're talking about this dumb
tweet
but i also you know i i thought all the
trump stuff was wasn't gonna work and it
will and it worked i i feel like what
ends up happening with people like
marjorie taylor green or alex stein is
they take the brunt of the ire and then
a conversation is erupts around the
issue well and i think you nailed it
words like this the system is broken we
should be able to talk about it just
being like hey what's best for kids can
we have that conversation it shouldn't
be about you know
click bait tweets you know we we try to
have
i i'm just wondering if the time for
decorum is meaningless that the time to
for for
cordiality or uh collegial behavior is
just it's out well maybe she could at
least get a little more creative so that
her shock factor isn't at the expense of
others
because it's always offensive to one
group or another yeah but the issue here
is one neither side cares at all about
the other side so why why is why are the
democrats doing a one-sided january 6
trial because they don't care to
convince republicans they want to rile
up democrats to get them to vote they
think we've locked it in there's no one
else to get
get them riled up
marjorie taylor green i'd assume i i'd
i'll ask her like why like what was your
thought behind this tweet like
walk us through your creative process
please well it's it's an unserious tweet
like i mean hands down you i'm sure a
lot of people thought it was funny i'm
sure a lot of people no one thought it
was funny that's not true she's got
major fans she's huge she raised more
money i'm pretty sure than like any
other member of congress what is
happening because because she does
things like this yeah and that's why
trump was able to do it too no that's
yeah because there are a lot of people
who just
want the the symbols and the machine
behind what they oppose to be struck
down right
so for antifa it's a brick through a
window does the brick through the window
actually change the system no
it doesn't even start a conversation the
only thing i'd say to this is like i
don't like the tweet but she got people
talking about it the the the the uh
assistant secretary for the health and
human services is advocating for child
for children to get sex change
operations right okay well look fine
regular moderate individuals post
liberals disaffected liberals we can all
sit here and be like i don't like the
things she said it's like well who else
is calling out and standing up against
the government advocating for this kind
of stuff oh the worst part is going to
be when i meet her and i like her and
you will
that's the funny thing like i i told
jamie this before i was like jamie
you're gonna agree with everything she
says oh i hate it
i hate it so much we you guys won't tell
anybody right guys i can't lose the new
followers i got post cancellation come
on keep it between us
from things like this obviously people
are going to be like like
there's going to be a lot of people who
very much like what she said and she's
going to stand by what she said and be
like i'm allowed to say it and all that
stuff and she is and there's going to be
a lot of people
like us
former liberals or still traditional
liberals that have like aligned with the
moderates libertarians and wright
because the work stuff's crazy and we're
gonna like you know kind of be like uh
she's right but like did she have to say
it that way right and in the end um
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
because there's nothing that's going to
get me to join the side of those giving
sex change operations to children
so
it doesn't matter
she can say whatever she wants
twitter can choose to ban her or not
her saying something that i might not
like or saying something i agree with
but in a way i don't like won't change
the fact that the left already hates her
they're gonna keep hating her the right
likes her i just feel like both sides
have said
we've got everybody we can get let's
roll and if the left was intelligent at
all
they would
see
that even with that that that people
like us are aligning closer
with
ludicrous tweets like that
than the policies they're putting
forward and they would go hey maybe we
need to back up a little bit like maybe
we're screwing up if people are siding
with
this
there's two distinct cultures in this
country
and there's no mending that divide
anymore there was a period where it was
one country split splitting down the
middle but we are well past that point
this is an example of it what's
happening in uh with dc with colbert is
an example of it
there's team 18b there's team red
there's team blue and if a team red
person walks into the courtroom and it's
in a team blue district they're going to
be a like i think there's
i don't identify with political teams
like people that are like my team's the
right republican red my team's the left
democratic blue i'm like i got a team if
i'm on a team it's not a politics team
i'm bored with politics i don't like
blabber if it just i'm on team like
science if there's like a you know
quantum science team that's you know my
except
except ian if if you were criminally
charged
in dc
they would just convict you
simply because you're on this i wouldn't
make assumptions you never know
and it depends on what it's for and what
i did what do you mean sometimes people
deserve to be convicted
the colbert people are being released
the january six people are not and it's
the exact same crime
in fact well it's the whole people were
warned not to be there and they were
there after hours too they knew they
were so it's worse but the other people
were involved in a violent no there were
no attack on the building well they were
there this is a big problem when
someone's a half a block away from a
crime that's going on are they
implicated in the thing going on a block
away they're not
of course not so so in this building
those people on the other side of the
building should be released in my
opinion right but partly
so at the very least there may be people
who get released but my point is
it's not hypothetical bro like we're
watching it literally happen the the
previous administration is arresting
former trump officials steve bannon just
left court today
like he is being criminally charged
because the democrats have forced people
to go in and testify and provide
statements that they're taking out of
context in a non-adversarial show trial
for january 6. they put me in their
january 6 evidence
and my dad texted me about that and was
like hey where are you working and i was
like please please wait till send them
the op-ed i did send them newsweek and
say
newsweek was so shocked to see me
included in the evidence that they asked
me to write an op-ed because they were
like they put the fence sitter milk
toast guy
in with the guys calling for a red
wedding the point is
raskin doesn't care dude is literally
like 15 minutes away from us by the way
and we have employees in his district
they don't care my point is you were at
a time now where you ian might be like i
don't want to be on anyone's team that's
okay they chose for you
is like plato said i'm not a i'm not i'm
not against these people that's the
difference if you go into a situation
being like you all are gonna convict me
i know it those people are gonna be like
yeah we're way more likely to do that
now but if you go in there saying i've
got an idea to help us all they're going
to be way less likely to convict you
that's
i think you're just it's just it's just
social dynamics you i don't know why you
think you're you're you know outside
of what they're all actually what's
actually happening it's like you you can
watch it happen we can see it happen you
can comment on it happening saying it's
wrong and then be like but it wouldn't
happen to me i don't get it i just want
to live in ian's world you seem he seems
so much happier that way it's resolution
i was like ian what yeah like i'm
picturing ian in the courtroom like
brothers sisters come together can't we
all get along and it was like yes that's
what i want i'm not even making fun of
you
i'm talking about like pulling carbon
out of the atmosphere we can get lots of
says your honor i don't care what ian
just said because of who he affiliates
with
like they did with steve bannon cringe
okay who's this juror that doesn't care
about the evidence
can i defend myself in this clown trial
you've created yes and right now
right now with steve and that's what's
happening what's going on with him what
so apparently and again i i saw a report
someone said a juror told the judge i
don't care what he should be extracted
from the courtroom yes exactly
point in dc we are literally watching
people get released from committee of
crime in which they were warned not to
do it did it anyway and on january 6 a
69 year old cancer patient is going to
jail for two months
it is a two-tiered system i don't know
what she did i don't know the extent of
why fair point i don't either but she
was she was charged with trespassing
that would have been funny if like we're
defending her and she was just planting
explosions she's on the side
she's the one that was waving him in
yeah exactly um with the uh she's like i
only have a little bit to live let's
take this place down
i i don't know i i don't think that
people that have been trespassing right
now on capitol property should be
arrested at all i'm not playing double
standards here i'm not like well they
did it to them which was wrong so do it
to them which will still be wrong two
wrongs don't make a right what i'm
saying is in this situation you are
subject to the same system as everybody
else i understand that part right you
you you might say like i don't want to
be your team and i totally get it you're
right but you are whether you want to be
or not well and they will choose
we have personal tribes and friendships
and communities and stuff like that but
he doesn't have to be a political team i
never believed this and and i was you
know but
tim made this point the last time i was
on the show and unfortunately it's like
from what i've seen on social media it's
like you're right which is
the right is far much more accepting
right now to people with diverse views
than the left is and and i know that
because people on the left who have been
fans of mine who when i started coming
on this show without listening would be
like you're out and then people on the
right
who found me on this show will write me
and go hey man i don't agree with you
but like i'm glad you're on the show or
whatever and to me one of the reasons
that i was on the left that i loved
about it was we were supposedly the
party of inclusion right and now you are
far more likely like you're saying man
to be completely cut out whether it's in
the court of law whether it's on social
media
even in like friendship groups i'm
hanging out with far more conservative
people who probably disagree with me on
a lot more than i would be with like a
lot of my old woe
i i am coming to believe for a variety
of reasons some private reasons
that the left and the right are being
divided among a
what's the uh um a propensity towards on
the right
morality like a sense of honor duty and
responsibility and the left is ignorance
or malice
and so i say tendency or propensity
towards the right has bad people
obviously the right has grifters the
right has all that but it's the
exception if you look at as i mentioned
with the bias checker you look at people
on the right you'll see they're fairly
bounced and trying to understand the
world you'll see that they're very much
about you know duty or family or
protecting or creating and then you look
at the life and it's very much about me
me mine i get i want the picture of leah
thomas on the podium
standing by themself where the other men
are walking away like the entirety of
the event is saying to you
we do not like what you are doing right
here
but they don't care they say i'm happy
you have stories of these contests
skateboarding contests where no one will
clap or cheer for the biological male
competing against females
they don't care they laugh and they say
so what i get mine did you see that
recently leah thomas was nominated for
ncaa woman of the year award yeah
alongside riley gaines who was a swimmer
who spoke up about tying with her and
being pushed off the podium photo
it's shocking
and someone from upenn
didn't get that opportunity at all
yeah thanks for checking out this clip
from timcast irl come hang out live
monday through friday at 8 pm eastern
time super chat we'll even answer some
of your questions if you want to check
out the after hours censored show go to
timcast.com and become a member we put
those up monday through thursday at 11
pm they're very funny not very family
friendly we'll love to see you there
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time